présidentielle chevaux
charles berling
il m'a vu souvent l'afr s'arrêter à ces
messieurs
m
je parais spéculation avec le full
s'appuyer sur cette touche enfin est ce
qu'on peut avoir un assistant oui est ce
quelqu'un melinda la méline tu viens tu
as plus là dessus
voilà sois gentil parce que moi il faut
jeter review par filiation lâche ça fait
quoi
merci tu sous un voile noir mais moi
j'ai un truc ici qu'il gèle aussi bien
comment ça m'a pas mal
le vin look très classique où j'ai fait
comme vous allez vous est vachement bien
karolina kurkova et du mannequin de
l'année je sais elle fait tout les
couvre de vogue us le temps les regarde
on comprend pourquoi
quelle est elle est sympa et tout elle a
toutes les qualités pour lancer un petit
peu vous parler français bonjour ma
belle
ernie très beau
alors vous publié chez albin michel un
livre qui s'appelle lentement place de
l'église pascal sevran
tu le dois pour voir des choses
peut-être maintenant livrée avec mon
livre ouais non pas le vôtre et si oui
est pas bon non regarde le doigt tant
pis tant pis mais ça me plaît beaucoup
et bien alors ce livre reprend place de
l'église
c'est le quatrième volet d'un journal
que vous avez commencé avec la vie sans
lui
deux cent mille exemplaires chacun ce
qui fait 800 milles du canal alors huit
cent mille exemplaires
pascal sevran ça fait beaucoup d'argent
non oui mais ça fait beaucoup d'impôts
d'accord enfin vous avez quoi vous avez
quand même 15 20 francs par exemplaire
non j'ai pas demandé faudrait que je
leur demande
vous parlez en france vous êtes comme
moi vous êtes à peu rétro mon cher
thierry tu tues moi rétro que vous je
vais pas tourner en rond non mais
maintenant sérieuse les moyens d'arrêter
la télé ou pour y arrêter de faire de la
télé vous aussi non non moi je peux
encore non je disais ça parce que ça
vous aurait permis de sortir de votre
schizophrénie pascal sevran
à un moment dans votre livre lentement
place de l'église où vous êtes dans un
village de la france profonde
morterolles votre fameux morterolles
vous êtes dans le silence depuis huit
jours est en train d'écrire
et puis vous vous regarder chanter
danser à la télévision et vous dites le
décalage entre mon personnage public et
moi est incompréhensible c'est à 40 vous
reconnaissez pas sur l'écran vous parlez
de gouffre entre l'homme des lumières
est l'homme de l'ombre celui de
morterolles il vous dit à un moment
c'était car tellement deviendra
insupportable
j'aime beaucoup la chanson donc je ne
renie pas du tout l'homme un peu
enthousiaste accordéon les vestes de
tintin ça fait rien et bien c'est moi
aussi abandonné un homme se rassemblent
au fil du temps je ne renie rien de cela
mais il est évident que quand je suis
dans mes province un petit peu comme ça
enfermé dans l'écriture qui compte aussi
beaucoup pour moi et dans le silence je
me regarde je dis c'est incompréhensible
mon père ne comprenait pas non plus
alors il ya deux pascal sevran a que
deux sèvres
il ya le parisien monde a un qui va dans
les régions où louis valentin
un peu comme vous balancer un peu sur
tout le monde les propos mouillé décide
quoi alors il ya le pascal sevran
parisien et puis elle morte héros les
oies comment je pense comment on dit
d'ailleurs
ouais j'en sais rien c'est joli le nom
morterolles mais marche roll c'est beau
c'est joli ça chante un peu célia mord
dedans et profite mais fait il ya le jeu
reste très triste et très oui ça m'a
beaucoup frappé les mots mort dans morte
europe pour des raisons que vous
imaginez et là où ils sont moins comme
mortal haute vienne sur le papier c'est
au nord mon jeu la porte d'orléans pour
vous c'est à provins mon cher notre
morterolles 7 au nord de la haute-vienne
voilà voilà
au nord de la haute-vienne t'imagines
cela l'on s'aime pas perdre d'argent ont
fait trois ans qu'on revenir non c'est
vrai nom alors le mortirolo zouaoui là
comme andy murray comme ça dans dans le
silence dans la douleur bah oui si vos
deux faces vous êtes vous êtes un janus
c'est du pipeau capable fils bien alors
que veulent les goûts dans lequel seront
d'ailleurs sont aussi réactionnaire d'un
claude puel et autour on pourrait dire
vous avez la nostalgie comme ça d'une
france où les oulémas son mason ou les
jardiniers jarny laissant tricote un
c'est pas très bon on a expliqué très
agacé par l'histoire de l'éducation
nationale on a expliqué que les jeunes
gens devaient avoir le bac absolument
clair au fond qu'on a absolument
dévaloriser les vrais métiers
je vois qu'on est fêlée et les
techniques modernes l'ordinateur serait
très important sauf qu'on a fait des
générations de chômeurs et un jour à
midi à nicole notât pourquoi ne
parlez-vous jamais l'apprentissage
almadies tous être charmante amy c'est
démodé
j'ai trouvé que c'était pas possible de
dire cela et les lits des imbéciles
qu'il faille aller à l'école jusqu'à 32
ans le bac + 42 mouret de chômeurs
paraît ridicule
je crois qu'il ne faut pas décourager
les garçons et les filles qui veulent
faire des métiers magnifique comme seul
comme ce que j'évoque là c'est pas une
nostalgie est la vie de tous les jours
tous les jours on a besoin de maçons de
plombiers etc
je trouve que cette sorte de folie qui
s'est emparée des ministres successifs
et surtout ceux de gauche
comme quoi il fallait à l'école
indéfiniment pour une faire une
génération d'abrutis ça ne me plaît pas
voilà et alors il ya un truc qui faisant
digne c'est les et boueuse ce que je
veux dire c'est que j'ai une très haute
idée de la femme et je n'aime pas quand
elle s'abaisse à notre niveau
j'ai une assistance en clair maintenant
or vous regrettez les maisons de
correction oui il faut dresser les
garçons c'est leur fait du bien c'est un
fantasme que vous avez on se dit non je
trouve que c'est bien un petit peu
d'hommes et est un peu l'éducation c'est
pas mal je n'ai beaucoup aimé cela il
appelle magnifique là dessus c'est pas
mal si on voulait trouver un jeune et
par siècle
ça c'est pas mal donc on peut dresser
les garçons oui c'est pas mal vous
regrettez par exemple qu'il n'y ait plus
que des écoles mixtes vont regretter
l'époque où les gars sont montés sur
monté sur le mur aujourd'hui c'est vrai
que les filles se font violer dans les
chiottes des lycées c'est moi je trouve
que c'est pas possible non plus je
trouve que on le voit ça se passe très
mal
il faut un temps pour tout je vois qu'un
reportage d'autres jours croix sur
france 2 sur les écoles aux états unis
commença à séparer un jour les filles et
les garçons se retrouveront quand il le
faudra mais je trouve que ça n'est pas
possible et et s'ouvre et là je suis
absolument sérieux il se passe des
choses pas possible dans les écoles les
enfants c'est très dur l'enfance et les
garçons déjà entre eux se castagnent
elles et ils sont au milieu c'est pas
possible c'est une grande connerie de
giscard d'estaing voté par la gauche
il ne faut pas faire la mixité à l'école
voilà grade
je suis pour la mixité à l'école sur le
site et les courants pop comme tout le
monde évidemment c'est moi je suis pas
comme tout le monde a son sens je ne
serai pas habité par vous ce soir vous
regretté pascal sevran vous regrettez
les bordels
ça vous gêne je vais le rejoindre c'est
à dire que c'est à dire que soyons deux
secondes sérieux là dessus l'hypocrisie
qui consiste à dire qu'il faut réduire
la prostitution est grotesque il faut
respecter ces femmes et ces hommes qui
donnent leur corps comme d'autres
donnent leur esprit il ne faut pas les
mépriser
il faut mettre en prison et pendre les
proxénètes et faire les choses joliment
ya une très belle littérature sur sur
les maisons ça peut être très bien on
peut surveiller cela que les jeunes et
femmes ne soient pas battus humiliés
torturés
ce qui est scandaleux en conséquence de
quoi celles qui ont choisi sans aucune
contrainte de donner leur corps et il ya
des hommes qui ont besoin de cela on ne
peut pas être hypocrite sur ce sujet
c'est insupportable
donc je dis qu'il faut pas tout les
proxénètes protéger les filles et les
garçons qui souhaitent faire offrande de
leur corps pourquoi moi je peux
reprendre le peu de talent que j'ai avec
ma plume chacun le sien n'ai pas envie
de rire de cela c'est très grave et très
sérieux et oui en effet il faut
organiser la prostituée accord joliment
la pub on l'applaudît de l'otan la curie
à l'époque où il y avait des bordels y
avait des bordels de deux garçons y
avait des garçons et wendel stemi que
j'ai pas gratuit un petit peu c'est
moins demandés ouais mais se demander
comment organiser sa housse est très
gentil le commerce du corps est une
chose très joli quand elle n'est pas
contrainte soit il faut de tout les
pouvoirs publics doivent s'occuper en
priorité de s'occuper des salopards qui
abusent des femmes
ouais hein ça on doit s'en occuper et
pour le reste les femmes et les jeunes
gens font ce qu'ils veulent de leur
corps alors quand on regarde votre
bouquin quand on regarde la couverture
vas-y zoom zoom mon garçon il ya un
petit village comme ça qui rappelle la
fiche pétainiste de françois mitterrand
là la force tranquille et on pense un
peu à la france moisie dont parlait de
philippe sollers dans le monde mais
philippe soler dit beaucoup de bêtises
oui la france moisie moi je ne trouve
pas six mois six là c'est beaucoup de
mépris pour les gens qui l'habitent
je ne dis moi je suis assez misanthrope
vous l'avez noté tout à leur jeu
aussi dira pas que la france soit pas ce
qu'est ce que c'est que ces termes un
peu vulgaire pour décrire les chasser et
la famille d'où je viens c'est une
france non mais ce nième fois de france
moisie sais tu disais qu'on irait [ __ ]
parce qu'il n'ya pas de france moisie
france monsieur solaire ça les fantasmes
c'est une france un peu pétainiste comme
ça c'est sacré vieux mot ça ne leur ait
pu coûter mon cher thierry vous êtes
troupes qu'à cultiver en politique pour
savoir que la france pétainiste était
gaulliste
trois ans plus tard oui oui d'accord
enfin l'a été je peux le ptc la même oui
d'accord j'avais d'ailleurs
alors alors alors quoi non mais c'est
incroyable même cheval votre mentor
c'est emmanuel berl c'est d'accord bien
est un grand philosophe quand même écrit
les discours de pétain écrit la terre
elle ne ment pas je hais les mensonges
qui nous ont fait tant de mal vous le
dit très bien c'est travail râble hé bé
tron langue française
les discours du maréchal pétain qui
était alors le vainqueur de verdun qu'il
avait promulgué aucune loi scélérate qui
l'a promulgué deux ans plus tard à vichy
et emmanuel bayle qui était la
conscience du siècle le grand philosophe
juif quand on lui a demandé de réécrire
aura été en français les discours du
maréchal pétain a cru bien faire
à l'époque il wright est les discours du
vainqueur de verrouiller oui enfin vous
raconter dans votre bouquin c'est pas un
secret que je dévoile pascal vous
raconter dans votre bouquin qu'à la fin
des dîners chez vous ça vous plaît mais
les champs lewis y reviendrez vous il
chante maréchal nous voilà
c'est très amusant quand bonnet g et
vous tomberez il ya des gens qui
savaient pas rire du tout pour manier
gens quand leurs parents des dangers
dans les camps de concentration je suis
avec vous que vous chantiez maréchal et
bien moi je sais c'est normal que ça
fasse pas rire à certaines personnes ça
vous amuse follement je le sais car il
en sait beaucoup permet se déroule
fassiez vous mettiez dans le limbourg et
je me change de mains je ne me prive de
rien jouer s'ils disent que je suis là
je dois dire
et puis je suis au tout tout soupçon
présent ce domaine oui j'ai passé ma
jeunesse prêt d'emmanuel berl way dans
le genre antisémite c'est pas mal oui
alors pas de leçons là-dessus c'est quoi
non moi je crois que vous êtes en fait
un vrai mitterrandien
ça c'est vrai avec ce que ça de
socialistes et de pétainiste c'est à
dire une idée de la france une idée de
des lettres de l'âme française
petit à petit ça va dit moi je veux bien
chose tout ça me fais pas partir comme
ça dans ce politiquement correct qui
m'écoeure donc je suis pas accepter cela
oui j'aimais françois mitterrand je les
respecte et je les dis je ne renierai
pas ce que m'a apporté cet homme même un
même quand vous avez appris qu'il était
le pote de bousquet que oui pendant la
guerre il a eu la francisque par
l'histoire vous le savez le faire par
les maîtres très bon là dessus oubliez
tout ça quand il a déjeuné avec bousquet
il avait là bousquet venait d'avoir la
légion d'honneur qui a été remise par un
tribunal à la libération fait de
résistants et de grands juif qui avait
remis la légion d'honneur à bousquet je
suis fatigué de vérité serait également
va donner à papon alors bien alors dans
ces dîners je vous racontais ça je
trouve ça extraordinaire
vous avez un jeu forcé alors prochain
dîner oui oui je vais vraiment parce que
vous avez un jeu le j'adore c'est abel
le jeu du qui est mort c'est un jeu très
spécial qui est mort brison jour très
cultivé il y avait des pas patrick
besson et c'était tout à fait les
garçons là toute sa bande d'écrivains du
figaro ils sont très bons les et alors
on s'amuse beaucoup et ça mais qui est
mort c'est très bien on oublie des fois
on se dit ah mais justement claude
autant lara est ce qu'il est bon oui il
est mort gérard manset non enfin presque
pierre messmer non jean-jacques
servan-schreiber
non il est pas mort noyé souffrent ils
souffrent raymond poulidor nom assez bas
c'est mon pays là il ya à côté chez moi
andré stil alors andré stil membres du
jury de l'académie française
la jambe arrière parce que c'était le
prix lénine ans a reçu un accueil
extraordinaire et ma mère lisait dans
les journaux communistes les livre
d'andré style et je disais à bessan
autre jour est ce qu'il est mort il m'a
dit non ouais alors votre journal hier
que vous et moi qui savais qu'ici non
votre journal donc le quatrième tome
lentement place de l'église prouve en
tous les cas un truc c'est que
l'homosexualité vraiment entré dans les
moeurs c'est à dire que maintenant elle
nous donne des idées
il ya des dizaines de lecteurs qui
compatissent à la disparition de votre
ami stéphane circuler les bonnes femmes
qui d'habitude lisent les bouquins de
arnie arnaud de madeleine chapsal elles
lisent
bouquin le fait que ce soit un garçon ça
pose pas de problème elle ne lisent
comme si c'est une fille
donc ça prouve que l'homosexualité
rentrer dans mes mains oui l'amour ne
pose pas de problème ouais et je m'en
doutais un peu j'en ai eu la
confirmation et ces questions les gens
ne se pose pas nous sommes des pauvres
gens des hommes et des femmes brisées et
qui passons notre vie à courir après
cela et l'amour emporte tout en
conséquence de quoi
heureusement dans ce monde dans lequel
nous vivons en france et ça arrange
beaucoup au pays et la jeunesse n'est
pas pour rien tout ça ne pose pas
question moi je n'ai jamais posé cette
question d'histoire de c'est très peu
important la sexualité la sexualité
c'est une affaire pour rigoler ou pour
faire des bébés
et encore le reste ça occupe assez peu
de temps dans la vie ce qui occupe
beaucoup de temps dans la vie c'est
l'amour est ce que retiennent les gens
qui veulent bien me lire c'est l'amour
au-delà de tout il s'agit ce n'est pas
exact et cela me réconcilie un peu avec
le genre humain
mais c'est la première fois qu'un livre
qui raconte comme ça là un couple
homosexuel séparés par la mort à au
succès public aussi important oui voilà
ce que je voulais dire oui voilà
l'homosexualité est elle mise donc à l
inverse on reproche de plus en plus
souvent maintenant aux homosexuels leur
pouvoir me chercher c'est ce que fait la
main qu'avec les nouveaux merde à la
main de travail du chapon le sait depuis
longtemps oui il y aurait travaillé au
monde veut tout dire
mais c'est vrai qu'à comme un pouvoir
qu'est aujourd'hui dans ce pays on
savait bien non du tout un banc elle
pouvoir gay monbahus garçon sait c'est
grotesque quand on a une énergie quand
on a un petit talent quel que soit qu'on
soit écrit ma garagiste chanteur hou hou
hou plombier est ce qu'on vous demande
avec qui vous coucher à cet
invraisemblable on se demande de vous
réparez vos tuyaux de tuyauterie de
baignoires et on ne sait jamais la
question vous ne vous demandez pas si
vos jardiniers ou votre chauffeur taxi
aime les filles les garçons nous n'a pas
de sens bien en tous les cas vous dites
dans votre livre que vous avez jamais
remplacer stéphane aujourd'hui vous
n'avez pas de fiancé je crois qu'on peut
le dire
pascal un nom mais plusieurs oui oui
vous dites mais à mon sens de passage
oui vous avez rien à leur dire après le
sexe dont vous préférez pas les voir là
vous préférez vous dit l'amour vous
ennuie la mosson contre on peut pas
aller voilà on se dit finalement jeu
et après dîner avec des femmes qui
lisent mes livres c'est bien c'est ce
que vous dites oui c'est ce que je pense
oui car maintenant donc c'est juste le
sexe d'un côté et l'esprit de l'eau
salée on ne cherche pas l'amour comme et
comme les champignons je veux dire par
font se défont la trappe des champignons
encore oui ça j'ai entendu ça quelque
part je voulais préparer obligé de faire
belle fille je vous avais préparé non
mais donc ça vous permet d'écrire la
tête l'ipsa c'est à dire qu'une fois que
vous avez fait l'amour disons peau mais
c'est commun c'est comme boire à peu
doué c'est une chose amusante un instant
bien pascal aucune importance vous savez
pascal qui est un grand classique dans
cette émission gars je vous regarde tout
le travail c'est de l'arthrose
l'interview à l'arthrose alors on la
parfaite depuis septembre mais ce soir
spécialement pour vous j'ai ouvert
l'interview alerte rose non bleus font
très bien
tout à fait
un de chaque côté comme à l'époque
d'ailleurs toros voilà voilà
vous le connaissez j'ai succès vous êtes
très bien là vient alors pascal
interview verte bleue est ce que vous
préférez draghi ou vous faire draguer me
faire dengue est ce que vous ferez
embrasser ou vous faire embrasser pour
faire embrasser caresser ou vous faire
caresser le faire grâce à arette d'un
début d'érection la tristesse il faut
larguer ou faire larguer largué vous
préférez un mec qui bosse bien mecha
infidèles ou un mec qui baisent mal mais
qu'est fidèles un mec qui baisent malves
été fidèle à huy non c'est le contraire
si votre partenaire vous propose une
partie à trois vous préférez que ce soit
une fille ou un garçon
ah ça peut être amusant avec une fille
ouais comme quoi ça c'est déjà fait vous
préféreriez faire l'amour avec 1000 mec
toujours de la même façon
ou avec un mec mais le mille façons
différentes je pas obsédé par ça du tout
rêver nord salam us très peu de temps
oui bah je sais pas moi collée du viagra
on sort très bien
simplement grâce à un but alors que
ces garçons
mon rêve
ça
et maintenant